bon alors maintenant vous allez demander
de chanter une chanson qui figure dans
votre premier 33 tours
c'est une donc ça datait de 58
c'est une sur le même album alors album
la licence de disques il y avait le
poinçonneur des lilas il y avait la
femme d un sou le corps des autres il y
avait 12 balles dans la peau il y avait
11 58 qui est une périphrase très libre
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire d'un
célèbre poème de ronsard
alors voilà on aurait pu choisir le lis
tu as abusé à nabokov bien entendu les
conquérants de heredia ou la chanson de
prévert mais j'ai préféré donc on sarr
58 qui est très jazz jazz
si je fais des pins on n'arrête pas les
enfants
t'en vas belle de chouettes avantage
3 à taux rajusté thorshavn et là
commence soumet au rivage
et des pics fermement que tu auras
division
tu auras des bagnoles de type bien
simple on du s1 tu feras des sourires
toujours là mais tu ne seras jamais
tous les mecs dans le fond ce le même
travail
et son prix on sent les bars à ce
qu'elle fasse vraiment
les pasdarans
d'ailleurs un beau jour pas du tout
moment convaincu de signer un serment
alors charles tu te dira quoi pour moi
elle avait du monde tant qu'écrivain
c'est tout ce que tu auras la gueule à
littérature où tout est foutu
c'est toujours très plaisant
des anciens membres du titre gang
c'est le soulier moi tu ne seras pas
moche
il est garanti
ruto parenthèse éternité cément surtout
tend vers la fin le via le vieux père 11
à bijoux
alors